will we give cartesian terms right I
can't say this kind of stuff I'm
forgetting about the fact that the
parameter exists right oh yeah 05
parabola I'm just going to call it x1 y1
okay that's the name of some point of
the parabola when you're working in the
textbook or in the question and there
are no it means these are not to think
Cartesian if there's no parameters
you're thinking Cartesian oddly okay
what remember I don't have to just say
x1 y1 I could if it's convenient to me
say x1 what's why we aren't going to be
equal to it's going to be x1 squared on
for a if I would make why the subject do
you see that x1 squared on for a okay so
so both of these are true right I can
view them as just two different numbers
or I can view them as linked together
because they are right on the basis of
this we came up yesterday with the
equation for the tangent at x1 y1 does
anyone remember what it is it starts at
the next year good x x 1 equals to a y
plus y1 very good okay now don't feel
too bad if you're not memorizing these
we've only just met them and there are
so very many okay as with most things
you'll become more familiar with them as
you use them okay which is what we'll do
later today and on Friday as well now
yesterday I did not devote any time to
developing the result further normal
okay and that's for two reasons number
one it's super easy to get the equation
of the normal you can work out the
gradient just like we did before and
then you pop it into point grading form
okay that's the first reason it's easy
to get the second reason is let me write
it for you here we go
there you go there's the equation of the
normal now having taught maths for a
while now right I had to develop all
these little tips and tricks for
memorizing things that are very very
hard to memorize in all my years I have
never come up with something that makes
this nice and elegant to memorize there
is no form of it that is nice and like
oh this is really nicely factorize a lot
kind of thing remember we did a bit of a
trick here just simplify this one we got
rid of the x1 squared in this line so it
looks quite nice where this guy just
can't do it right you can't put it in
other forms but the other forms you get
tend to confuse you with the other
equations that you really want to
memorize in those particular forms so I
don't think it's worth putting any
effort Scott I'm really kind of just
putting him there for the completeness
because you have the tangent and normal
for parametric representation so now you
have the tangent and normal for a
Cartesian one in a way of speaking I
find that and personally I'm just
speaking from my own experience from
being in year eleven twelve learning
this um what you just said is exactly
the kind of thing that is very easy to
connect right it's like oh I just put
the wrong side and then you have a
completely different equation minor
minor details changed dramatically so um
if it is if you memorize then a thumbs
up to you but I think most people will
find that is not the case okay so we
have one last result to work on okay now
when you have a look at this list which
do you think it would be what do you
think is missing from the list it looks
like the equation the Cartesian equation
for a court I've got tangent normal cord
and I've got tangent normal okay that is
true kind of okay we're going to look at
a very special cord and I'm going to
explain to you by way of this diagram so
you need a nice big parabola drawn on
here and we're going to I'm going to
tell you about a very special cord that
has to do with some of the results we
already have here okay so wait for you
to draw your parabola most of you are
miss the way there okay you can finish
it as I'm speaking
he's what we're going to do um we've got
so far all of this language right I need
to add a teeny teeny little bit more see
I point on the parabola we're just
naming it for the sacred convenience x1
y1 okay for what I'm about to do I want
to put this model on the parabola
specifically I want to point it's
outside the parabola so for example if
we all draw a point may be down here in
the third quadrant just so we're all
looking at something consistent
something like that okay sega oh sorry
clearly our way what an amateur hour
right one two three four okay now i'm
gonna call this point p right pivot
point and distinguish it with a put-on
it's outside right i'm going to call
this not why not that's a very arbitrary
distinction I call could have call to
anything I like okay but your text books
do this and so at least we'll be talking
in the same language okay now from any
point outside the parabola grab your
rule on I that's any point up travela I
can always draw a pair of tangents to
the parabola does that make sense yeah
it's just like a circle it's which is
why a lot of the language it should use
of course okay so what I'd like is to
now is get your all right and carefully
draw in the pair of tangents they go for
our external point up to our parabola do
it as carefully as you can so you can
see here right I've drawn a pair of
tangents this gives me a pair of points
new points right so i'm going to call
this point over here a and this point
over here be they are points on the
parabola right so i'm going to name them
in this scheme right i'm going to call a
x1 y1 it's on the parabola and b is the
next one I want so I'm going to call it
x2 y2 okay so X naught Y naught is off
the parabola and be x1 y1 x2 y2 there on
the parabola okay so now that we have
got those two points right these are the
points of contact between the tangents
from this point and there's two tangents
so there are two points of contact the
two point
of contact megacoin right that caught in
there and I'm putting it in a nice
different color that bore their this
special or just a quarter the latus
rectum is a special cord because it's
the cord drawn between these two points
of contact I call it the good good cord
or contact okay this is a special cord
it's a quarter contact because it's that
it's okay i'll say that again it's
called the court of contact because it
joins the point of from there okay so in
some senses i could draw that cord
without knowing where the tangents are
because this point is really what tells
me where where the tension arts hard to
visualize what on earth is going on ok
so the court of contact this is this
last Cartesian equation we're going to
derive okay the proofs a bit weird i'm
going to show you the proof um it's hard
to follow what I learnt it I found it
very difficult to follow every time I've
taught it students have found it
difficult to follow it's not difficult
to follow because long and complicated
in fact it's one of the very shortest
proof that I know one two three four
five five lines not long okay what's
problematic about it is that it goes by
so quickly it's like what just happened
like you look at it you'll look at my
lines i could give you my five lines and
you'll look at it and not know what's
going on so what I want to do is I want
to give you kind of like a better
pretext to what's going on a prologue if
you like a prologue is what you get
before a story so the story makes sense
okay if I chapter 0 if you like okay so
what I'm going to do words seem
immediately relevant okay but i want
this category in your head so that when
i get to the proof i hope it will make
things click that's my goal okay